all right so fluorescence you know I
know you hear this from me a lot but
this really is my favorite topic the
applications of luminescence and
fluorescence and service to biology are
incredibly important so what I'm going
to try to do in these two lectures is
explain to you the difference between
fluorophores that we can encode into
proteins through genetic engineering and
fluorophores that we use that are made
by chemists in a lab but then appended
to molecules so today we'll talk about
the nuts and bolts of fluorescence and
then on Wednesday we'll start to see
some of these tools that you've seen
images of U of we love to wow you with
images of fluorescent cells and cells in
action but I want to step back and
actually show you how that all came
about where do these fluorescent
proteins come from what are we looking
for how much protein engineering was
done to make these such an amazingly
useful set of molecules macromolecules
to really allow us in real time to study
biology and there are many many other
applications as well so we're gonna talk
about luminescence and fluorescence in
general luminescence is the general term
and fluorescence is a little bit more
specific there are different types of
luminescence and you'll get to see some
of those varieties of luminescence I've
put a decent amount of our content today
on the screen so we'll go up here and
take a look
so luminescence in general is the
emission of light not associated with
heat not like a burning flame which has
a lot of light accompanying it but
rather the emission of light in the
absence of heat and there are different
types of luminescence the biologists use
intertwined into biological experiments
to illuminate life to understand details
of cellular activity but also as
reagents in
diagnostics in all kinds of imaging
modalities and through these two three
lectures actually because professor
Martin will give you one that has even
more imaging in it you'll sort of really
get to understand where these pretty
magical reagents come from so the two
types of luminescence that we won't
discuss in detail today
first of all chemiluminescence this is a
molecule known as luminol sitting in a
little vial ie I think I like
fluorescence so much because the images
are so captivating now things like
luminol has anyone heard of Neal in all
before does anyone what yeah do you
watch a lot of CSI or yeah so tell
everybody what what people use luminol
for yeah so when you see these TV shows
and you know there's this beautifully
clean motel room and nothing looks like
it ever happened there and there was you
know but people thought there was a
murder took place there you'll notice
they come in with these spray bottles
and spray all over the carpets and the
drapes and the chairs and then there's
this great moment where they turn off
the light and luminol interacts with the
heme of blood at an amazingly sensitive
level such that in when the lights are
turned out the rooms just sort of this
you know battlefield of bright
luminescence that indicates that this
was a crime scene so that's the most
famous luminol sort of a example so that
is what would be called
chemiluminescence the interaction of a
chemical with another chemical to give
luminescence another pretty useful type
of luminescence is bioluminescence I've
done a lot of scuba diving in my life
and there's nothing more exciting than a
dive at night where the whole ocean is
this sort of inky black and sometimes
you'll move your arms through the the
black water at night and you'll see all
this is like little fireworks and many
many organisms marine organisms actually
undergo bioluminescence it's a
biological reaction that causes
luminescence and this is a cattle
first shown here in this image in the
corner where they are brightly lit at
night and actually it's just a whole
party there at night in the ocean where
all sorts of organisms are signaling to
other organisms through bioluminescence
and reactions such as luciferase
reactions so in bioluminescence a
molecule of ATP is generally used and
combined with another molecule through
the action of an enzyme that ends up
kicking out light energy so those are
both important but what we're going to
talk about principally is fluorescence
this is a more specific term and you may
wonder why I'm putting this in in
capital letters the first thing to learn
about fluorescence is how to spell
fluorescence so if you look at the word
fluorescence and the first word first
part of the word looks like flower you
know the stuff you bake your pumpkin pie
with you spelled it wrong it actually is
Flor ALU ores what are you guys
whispering about did I get something
else wrong yes yeah well forget about
that part yes there's another C in there
there we go its snuggle that in so the
important part is the first part so make
it look like you know what you're
talking about and spelled fluorescence
correctly I cannot tell you how many
papers
scientific papers I read where they
spelled fluorescence wrong it's really
hysterical it's one of those there's two
or three amazingly common typos in
people slides one of them is spelling
fluorescence wrong and the other one is
spelling com compliment wrong compliment
as opposed to compliment where you're
telling someone they look good and
compliment where you're trying to sort
of match up things anyway
but fluorescence is at key point so what
is fluorescence it's the absorption of
light energy
by a molecule now it could be a small
organic molecule it could be a small
part of a fluorescent protein molecule
that has a particular structure but it
will absorb light energy at a certain
wavelength so let's put this into just
the cuvette experiments this is these
are the kinds of little little
containers that we use for certain types
of fluorescence we could use a plate in
a plate reader but this is quite common
so you shine light on this molecule see
from an app the doors the outer doors on
both sides I don't know everybody's
pretty happy today anyway
and the molecule goes and I'm gonna just
draw something you know with a bunch of
double bonds and things and the bottom
the molecule absorbs light and goes to
an excited state so this is the ground
state before light after light you get
the molecule in an excited state so it
has absorbed that light energy so you've
hit it with a wavelength of light and
I'm gonna redefine all these terms
properly in a moment lambda excitation
of a particular wavelength once that
molecule has absorbed light there's a
very transient period until the molecule
lets out energy in the form of light
and returns back to its ground state now
so that the photo physics of
fluorescence involves the excitation of
a molecule with light of one energy that
light energy is at a particular
wavelength so it's called its lamda of
excitation that molecule very very
transiently it's usually picoseconds or
nanoseconds for organic molecules who
maybe a little bit longer for other
types of complexes and may stretch to
the microsecond or millisecond but most
of what we talk about will be Pico
second to nano second lifetime and once
it's excited it just drops its energy
back out and goes back to the ground
state and the most important thing that
you want to remember is the wavelength
which is given in nanometers and the
wavelength for emission which is also in
nanometers this wavelength is higher
energy obviously you don't create energy
when you shine light on something it's
not gonna you'd be breaking a few
fundamental rules if you did so the
light that comes back out is lower
energy because there's been a
rearrangements in the excited state of
the molecule so you can't possibly kick
energy out at a higher energy and so
this is a shorter wavelength the
animators and this is at a longer
wavelength okay so remember higher
energy a shorter wavelengths lower
energy or longer wavelengths and that is
a rule for fluorescence when you excite
a molecule you'll take it to the excited
state it'll sit and vibrate there a
little bit then it will kick back energy
out at a longer wavelength and from the
majority of the fluorescence experiments
that we do in biology the wavelengths
you see emission at or in the visible
range whereas the wavelengths that you
might excite your molecule at are often
in the UV or a bit longer
ideally longer and this these themes are
going to come up this isn't the first
time that you're gonna see them and it's
not it's not the last time you're gonna
see them so let's take a look
fluorescent dyes and the electromagnetic
spectrum in the next couple of slides so
what you see here okay you see a bunch
of little Eppendorf vials with
fluorescent molecules that emit light at
all different wavelengths these would be
down at the ultraviolet end of the
electromagnetic spectrum these would be
up in the red very red and the lowest
energy so these emission wavelengths
these would be emitting at the lowest
energy longest wavelength these would be
emitting at the shortest wavelength
lowest to the highest energy it's
everyone following me so just make sure
you remember that and just this
principle rule that you can't possibly
break with respect to the wavelengths of
light for fluorescence experiments so
what we're going to see is the
relationship to the electromagnetic
spectrum there's a little bit more
detail in a minute and then look at some
fluorescent dyes that are very very
commonly used in biology and in fact you
will have seen a lot of the a lot of
cells stained with these dyes even so
far in pictures that you've seen on the
screen and then we'll talk about the
application of antibody reagents and
where does that come in with respect to
fluorescence so let's take a look at
fluorescence in the electromagnetic
spectrum so here it is going from
wavelengths the ultraviolet wavelengths
would be shorter than 400 nanometers so
ultra violet so beyond violet and the
very red wavelengths would be in the
range from 600 to 700 and he
you see the relationship between
wavelength and then the what the light
emitted would look like so if we're
looking at hing what we would expect to
see is if we've got a fluorophore and it
shows fluorescence we would be exciting
the chlorophyll in wavelengths in this
region and we would see emission in
wavelengths in this region but a
cardinal rule is that we excite with a
shorter higher energy wavelength and
observe a mission at a longer lower
energy wavelength now there's very
important eyes straight away the most
common dye that you will see immediately
in biology is a dye known as a idiom
bromide and here's its structure you can
often recognize fluorophores they have
lots of rings fused together with lots
of double bonds in them and this is the
structure of a compound known as a idiom
bromide it's a dye that intercalates
into DNA and when the dye changes its
environment from being either and more
from being in water to being snuggled in
between stacks of base pairs in DNA it
changes its fluorescent properties and
it becomes fluorescence so fluorescence
isn't just the intrinsic shape of the
molecule and what it looks like it's
very very often related to what's around
it why does why is that the case it's
because the excited state may behave
differently in different environments
may be stabilized for a while and that's
why you might see fluorophores
experience a change in their
fluorescence as a function of their
environment is that clear to everyone so
the molecular environments if I'm a
fluorophore and I'm in water I'm gonna
feel pretty differently in my excited
state if I'm a fluorophore and I'm
sitting in fact between DNA bases it's
pretty dramatic when you see it so when
you mix Ophidian bromide with DNA and it
could be in a cell or it could be a
lysate from a cell where you're
capturing the DNA and trying to
manipulate it in recombinant biology
that Atheneum bromide will intercalate
into the DNA and it will light up as a
as a bright orange dye so here let's say
we've got a gel that we run DNA on we
might have a set of standards and in
other places we're looking for the size
of DNA remember that great experiment we
saw where we saw how quickly small and
large pieces of DNA ran through an
agarose gel so here is what the DNA gel
would look like if you soaked it in a
Sid ium bromide alright so here's the
gel there's a ladder of bands but then
let's say you wanted to do some work on
a piece of DNA and maybe ligated you see
DNA pieces at different wavelengths that
have different mobilities based on size
we couldn't see the DNA directly we
couldn't pick it up we couldn't
visualize it so we have to use ways to
visualize it one way is to radio label
it messy we don't really want to do a
lot of that if we can avoid it the other
way is simply to soak a dye into the gel
and the dye because of the positive
charge here the counter iron gets
displaced and the positive charge gets
attracted to the DNA and and associates
with it quite tightly so that would be a
way that you would observe DNA by a DNA
bound to a dye in a gel and this
fluoresce is a pretty long wavelengths
so this fluoresce is this bright orange
that's actually at about 6:05 so you can
see this is really in the visible range
6:05 would be right around here and it
has this bright kind of orange
fluorescence and the wavelength that you
would use to irradiate the dye on the
DNA would be at shorter wavelengths and
6:05 you'll often have a prescription
excite at this wavelength so you observe
at this wavelength and these are fixed
physical parameters so that fluorescent
molecules okay
now sodium bromide is a dye that can get
into cells and we can look at DNA within
cells and here's a picture of how it
would look so here's the the
vivianne bromide and here's a pair of
stacked bases this one and this one and
there he is right in the middle see that
that ring coming towards you is that and
then here's this thing that slides
straight between the bases and might
cause a little bit of a bulge and we
would call this a DNA in Turkey later it
slides into the DNA and you can see over
here the structure of DNA so you could
picture aetherium bromide sliding
between the bases now there's a big
problem here because you can't use DNA
Ophidian bromide it's pretty toxic why
would it be toxic well you know it's not
the broma it's the fact more think of
what the dye does when it gets to the
DNA what would that do to things like
replication and transcription it it just
kind of messes it up and so these are
toxic dyes that can only be used in
fixed cells to do observations of cells
so we use it a lot we need to be careful
of it because if it gets absorbed
through our skin it could get into
ourselves and it could interfere with
replication and other cellular processes
because it would accumulate on our
cellular DNA all right but so and in
fact the interesting thing that a lot of
molecules that actually have these sort
of flat pancake shapes with lots of
double bonds are actually pretty
important in biology because they end up
being chemo therapeutic agents so what
I've shown you here is what's known as
an anthracycline structure I believe
this is adriamycin I could be off but
it's a natural product that's isolated
from bacteria and it has this structure
that also makes it a DNA intercalate ER
and it's used as a cancer chemo
therapeutic agent because it interferes
with cell division and proliferation so
we actually exploit that property but
only with with cells that we want to
kill or stop dividing so you could
picture well
don't want to use something that's going
to interfere with cells if I'm doing
live cell imaging because I'm going to
have trouble with the properties of the
cells so fluorophores are great but
you've got to worry about them because
they can try and get transferred through
the skin through cellular membranes
because they're often quite greasy and
they can get in and interfere with
essential processes of DNA so because of
this there's been quite a revolution in
the work done with DNA binding agents
the bind a little differently in a way
less toxic so I want to describe to you
a series of dyes that are known as Dappy
and host h OE chst this was my I believe
discovered in by a company in Germany
and these are different kind of dies
that fluoresce on binding to DNA so
they're still useful in that same
context you can in fact substitute a
city and bromide with these dyes but
they bind to DNA pretty differently and
I want you to take a look at these
pictures so here in green and blue and
apologies to the colorblind you see a
molecule of this compound here bound to
DNA so it's pretty clear it's different
from intercalation right you can see
it's more sliding around one part of the
DNA and when those molecules bind to DNA
in water they don't fluoresce when they
bind to DNA they fluoresce an intense
cyan blue so that's at a shorter
wavelength from the etherium bromide so
taking a look at this structure does
anyone want to explain to me how the
molecules might bind to DNA what would
be wood we wouldn't call it into
collation we know intercalation is more
his perpendicular to the axis of the DNA
so we're looking at this do you think
these bind along a while ago when I was
talking about the structure of DNA I
like to think of DNA as having two
grooves two places where things combine
to it and I
that's a minor groove and then this big
trench is what's called the major groove
and certain molecules bind in one groove
and other molecules bind in the other
where do you think it's binding just by
inspection yeah that's correct it's just
snuggled just perfectly in the minor
groove if it was in the major groove it
would be swimming around in that groove
it's too almost too big so what's really
cool about these dyes is they slide in
between the into the minor groove and
they also make some contacts with the
phosphodiester backbone but it's not
that they're dancing on the
phosphodiester backbone they're
literally in the groove but there's some
opportunity for electrostatic
interactions and so these compounds
would be known to bind in the minor
groove and in fact they bind in
particular regions of DNA where there's
a T knot GC those are the places where
there's the just a pair of hydrogen
bonds instead of the trio that's just
their habit their personality all right
so chemistry was very important here you
had a good dye but it was toxic but
improved dyes came along that could be
used in living systems that are not
toxic because if you bind in those
grooves and you're dissociating easily
you're not going to interfere so much
with replication that makes sense so
it's a weaker force it's not going to
have a big detrimental effect now I
moved this slide up I realized he was in
the wrong place in the deck and this is
just an application of the butt of the
DNA minor groove binder host and in this
case we're looking at three cells okay
these two are not actively dividing but
take a look at this cell it's actually
clearly in the state preparing for cell
division and what you can see here is
that the in the nucleus the DNA is
pretty diffuse before things really
start to condense and line up for DNA
replication and cell division and what's
intriguing to me
is that this rather diffuse blue dye
that's probably a bit more loosely
associated with DNA becomes much clearer
and brighter when the chromosomes are in
this in the state they're in Purcell
division so you can see them here and
one question here so if you're looking
at cells you're trying to observe cells
where else in the cell are you going to
see DNA so we can see the nuclear DNA we
can see what stage of the cell cycle
it's in yeah comment yeah in the
mitochondria so you could also spot that
within the cell if you're at a
sufficient amplification so you know
that there's not DNA running around
everywhere it's literally in very
specific places with the cell these dyes
will bind also to other nucleic acids
but they don't bind so well because
those don't have the really repetitive
double stranded DNA double stranded
nucleotide structures but there are
other dyes to bind much more
specifically to RNA but we won't discuss
them so nucleic acids seem to be
something that we can definitely
pinpoint with fluorescence we can see
where it is we could follow cell
division we could look to see the
progress of cell division for example
upon adding things to a cell can you see
remember very very early on we showed
you slides movies of cells dividing you
could do that with this kind of dye
because it's a non-toxic dye all right
so wait so far so good
so the key thing though about biology is
we have so many other entities within a
cell that we want to be able to track
and monitor and what we needed what is
absolutely essential a reagents to do
that so I want to talk to you about
biological tools
the monitoring and you know what these
are these are antibodies monitoring
proteins and in fact you can also coax
antibodies to recognize carbohydrates so
I'm going to just put these here
they're a little bit harder to bind to
antibodies but nevertheless those are
useful so we're going to talk now about
antibodies which are agents of the human
adaptive immune system and how they have
been exploited intensively to study
biology now what you will learn from
Professor Martin in two or three
lectures time is much more about the
nuts and bolts of the immune cells of
the immune system and how it mounts a
response to disease and other features
I'm gonna focus completely on the
technological side of antibodies and how
they are useful reagents to study
biology because if you want to recognize
a protein in a Cell you need a
particular entity that will bind to that
protein and show you where it is through
some kind of signal for example
fluorescence so what I want to do is
give you the minimal description of
antibodies so you can understand this
but later you're going to revisit it in
a bit more complicated venue but for the
time being I'm just going to talk about
B cells which are cells that produce
antibodies and I'm going to talk to you
about how they recognize their targets
okay because what we have in the
adaptive immune system is an amazing
system where you can do Combinator
real biology and basically recognize any
target entity you're interested in so
let's take a look at this keeping in
mind that this is us explaining biology
to make reagents to do biology it's kind
of a cool sort of cyclical process so
the cells of the hemopoietic immune
sorry
the hemopoietic system those are the
ones that are important in blood cells
form a lot of difference for in a minute
I'm on triple-triple tools here there
are a bunch of different cells that are
produced from the pluripotent
hematopoietic cells they're either the
white cells or the red cell types but
what we're going to focus right in on
are the B cells these are the cells of
the immune system that produce
soluble antibodies okay and when you
challenge a b-cell population with a
foreign entity the b-cell population
will go into gear to produce antibodies
that very specifically recognize that
foreign target because in the human
adaptive immune system that might be a
wonderful tool to get rid of that
foreign entity so we're going to focus
exclusively on the B cells and the way
that they mature to produce soluble
antibodies those are down at the bottom
here based on what they've been
challenged with so what this little
schematic shows you is you have if you
have a bunch of different B cells and
there's something you want to recognize
let's just say it's a molecule an EGF
molecule a cytokine what you might do is
challenge this population with the
cytokine only one B cell type will bind
to the cytokine and then that will get
amplified and then you will end up with
B cells that produce a lot of an
antibody to a cytokine such as EGF I'm
truly gumming this down I just want you
to get the gist of it for the purpose of
this guy this discussion now B cells
adopt a very classical shape
and I'm just going to show you the
quaternary structure of a b-cell of an
antibody in linear form here so it
doesn't look very exciting right now
there are two light chains which I've
just shown in schematic form these are
just polypeptide chains and there are
two heavy chains all right so that's
their basic structure it's held together
in a stable quaternary structure with
this complex and there may be disulfides
across and throughout the structure now
what's so special about antibodies
they're pretty big molecules the
molecular weight is pretty high but the
key thing about antibodies is that the
majority of the structure stays fairly
constant so I'm just gonna so this
doesn't get get modified when b-cells
and mature but another part of the
structure is variable and when B cells
mature
there's loads of rearranging in that
variable section in order that it adapt
to bind a target so what you've seen
here is that the target let's see if
this little fellow works anymore now ah
what you see here is the light chaining
green heavy chain in blue and it's a
double version of it we always draw
antibodies as this V shape and then
antigen
you've heard this word before it's a
foreign entity that's foreign to the
immune system the antigen binding site
is right here at the tips of the
antibody and I think the picture up
there is kind of clearer just put that
forward again and you can see very
specifically the structure the C's
designate constant regions CC all the
way through here and there V's represent
variable regions which I've shown you
and that the tip of the B's are the
antigen binding sites so you're gonna
see more about the antibodies in the
immune system but what you want to
accept is that these are biological
macromolecules that particularly evolved
to recognize target antigens and you can
use them reliably as biological reagents
all right so how do you achieve the
diversity there are hundreds of
thousands of different antibodies in the
human system if we had a gene for every
single different light chain and every
heavy chain you know our DNA would be
completely swamped by being dedicated to
the genetic material for antibodies so
instead there is a particular system
which provides little portions of your
struck of the DNA structure that are in
little pieces of variable components
that can zips to get zip together
through transcription and slicing events
to give you a bunch of antibodies that
have different variable regions and this
is what's known as the bdj system and
you'll hear more about that from
Professor Martin so basically what you
want to think about it is it's a
combinatorial system to take little
pieces of DNA into a supra molecular
structure to give you antibody combining
sites that can recognize virtually any
target
anyone got any questions here I'm seeing
a few worried faces somebody asked me a
question if you feel I could clarify a
component of this or you okay with this
anybody okay I'll move forward so we've
talked about antibodies when you get a
population of B cells that produce
antibodies to a particular target these
may be what are known as polyclonal a
polyclonal a sir i should have written
that up here polyclonal antibodies as
might be suggested by the name is an
antibody but let's say it recognizes a
molecular entity so the antibodies I'm
gonna draw them as little Y shaped
molecules may recognize different parts
of the antigen so antibody a b c
recognize different parts of the antigen
those would be polyclonal it would be a
mixed bag of antibody molecules that
shows specificity for a target but
people also tend to use a great deal
monoclonal antibodies because they are a
lot more specific so if you had a
selection of polyclonal antibodies a
monoclonal antibody would be a single
population the recognizes a single
antigen or epitope in your antigenic
molecule and the way those are made is
through an engineering method where you
fuse spleen cells with myeloma cells and
then you get hybrid what are known as
hybridomas that produce very
specifically just monoclonal antibodies
so that's a bit of background there
about the antibodies you'll see it on
the rerun when Professor Martin talks
but I just wanted to give you a bit of
exposure to this
so let's now look at what how antibodies
can be useful so let's say you want to
visualize in a cell let's move straight
to a real targeted application we want
to make an antibody that might recognize
actin and a different antibody that
might recognize tubulin to take a look
at cells through the use of antibody
structures the way you generate
antibodies is through laboratory animals
and very commonly we use either mice or
rabbits for antibody production
the rabbit is used when you need a lot
more antibody material the mouse will
satisfy for some experiments so the way
you make antibodies is by in injecting
so this would be the foreign agent or
antigen that you want to make an
antibody to which would normally bind at
the variable region of this
immunoglobulin molecule you inject the
mouse with that antigen excuse me that
that's a rabbit you know I haven't been
in biology very long but I can tell
that's a rabbit right anyway so you
inject the rabbit with a human protein
if you and what would happen if you
injected the rabbit with rabbit acting
or with a rabbit Pro tubulin what would
you see would you expect to see a
response no right yeah because organisms
are adapted not to recognize their own
proteins unless there's some disorder
like an autoimmune disease so you would
inject the rabbit with a human epitope
so for example human actin generate
antibodies with a specificity for actin
and then you would label those
antibodies with a fluorescent marker so
you could track it or follow it through
chemistry alternatively you might want
to make a different antibody for tubulin
and then you would differentiate the
antibody against tubulin from the
antibody against actin by labeling it
with a different color fluorophore so
you've really got two types of macro
molecule that
be interacted with a fixed cell and
recognize those two macromolecules
within the protein so what's important
here is that you don't use the protein
from if you want to study human cells
you use antibodies produced in rabbit or
mouse if you want to study rabbit cells
you could produce it in different
organisms you what you're not going to
produce the antibodies in the same host
nowadays yes right oh okay so you would
prepare the you would do them there's a
lot of screening takes place so you
injects the mouse rabbit and then you
collect the serum and you look for
whether the serum gets enriched and
enriched in antibodies that recognize
the target so you'll see an increase in
what's known as the titer and then once
you get a high titer you'll so
unfortunately you can just collect the
serum or in depending if you want to
make monoclonal you'd have to sacrifice
the animal to get the spleen cells but
then you collect the antibodies through
an affinity method that's directed just
at antibodies then you've got your
population and you can throw a
fluorophore dye at it and chemically
label it so it's a good point there
there's a lot of work being done now
with antibodies from different organisms
in fact you'll see them from camelids
and there are also ones from shark and
the reason why they're kind of
interesting is that they sort of have
many antibodies that are much more
useful for technology so let's see what
we can do here we can do
immunofluorescence experiments in order
to do this with an antibody and this is
going to highlight a shortcoming of
antibodies you may take a cell that you
want to observe different proteins in
that cell you have to fix the cell to
make it permeable why do I need to make
the cell permeable in order to use these
antibody reagents
do you think the antibodies are just
gonna cross Dappy gets into a cell
easily but what about antibodies can
they cross the plasma membrane to get
into the cell to label a target what do
you think who says yes
who says no good thank goodness okay you
guys don't see much but I know you know
the answer here they just can't float
into cells they're too large to get into
cells so you have to fix the cells on a
glass side and perme alike permeable is
lies them for example with methanol so
that the antibodies can gain access to
all parts of the cell so here is a
bright field view of cells that's a
little bit more specific that's okay too
but this is what I really want to show
you this is what you could achieve with
Dappy and an antibody to actin and an
antibody to tubulin and you could look
at the various colors of the
fluorescence emission and you see here
what you've got is an anti acting
antibody with a red dye and you can see
that at the perimeters of the cells
you've got an anti tubulin antibody with
a green dye and you can see the the
filamentous structure there and then
you've got Dappy staining bright blue
where the nuclei are so you have three
unique labels that fluoresce at
different wavelengths and you can
directly pinpoint things so fluorescence
is extremely valuable for looking at
biological systems because we don't have
a lot that fluoresces in the body so a
cell in general if you irradiate it with
light you won't see any major
fluorescence at all so these reagents
that you use to study biology if they
fluoresce you've got unique signals
where you can look at really complicated
cells that may have thousands and
thousands of proteins sugars nucleic
acids and very specifically see things
by fluorescence because the fluorescence
is a unique signal in biology relative
to the intrinsic fluorescence of
proteins or other macromolecules
we have tryptophan and tyrosine a couple
of amino
acids they fluoresce but it's so dim
it's nothing like this you wouldn't see
those kinds of signals at all it's
really the what we call extrinsic
fluorophores fluorophores from outside
but shine very very brightly
many of these fluorophores shine so
brightly they can be used to look at in
single molecules Professor Martin
described to you single molecule DNA
sequencing that actually exploits very
bright fluorophores that are so bright
that you can see just a few of them in
one place very very clearly okay how am
i doing
I just want to actually leave you with
something that's another technology so
you could almost picture with all of
what we've seen so far
you could almost target any cell with an
antibody that's particularly
specifically raised to a particular
protein that's within the cell so Wilson
we can see and in the next class we'll
discuss what the limitations of that are
but we've already talked about the fact
that we have to use antibodies with
fixed not living anymore cells so
they're really dyes that can only be
used in that way the other place you can
use fluorophores is the labeling DNA and
for looking at DNA and a particularly
important technology is known as a DNA
microarray has anybody heard of these
yeah so DNA microarrays absolutely
exploits the complementarity of DNA
sequences so if you want to probe for a
particular sequence of DNA you would
make the complementary strand and label
it with a fluorophore
and you could out of thousands of DNA
stretches literally light up the stretch
of DNA that's complementary to your
target and so DNA microarrays what you
see here are just the size of just a
microscope slide where on this slide
through arraying technologies you can
literally spot 40,000 distinct sequences
of DNA in grids to recognize so these
DNA micro arrays can be used for
profiling
genetic material or for profiling not
just DNA but RNA and well sure we'll see
how at the beginning of the next class
in order to probe for particular
stretches of DNA that might be Deniz
disease related and have single
nucleotide polymorphisms so in order to
actually just give you a little bit of a
warm-up to that I want you to go I'm
gonna put a link to this in the website
and it actually just shows you virtual
virtual running of a DNA microarray
experiments and how you can use it to
profile disease states and cells or
versus healthy cells and then at the
beginning of the next class I'll
describe how you get information out of
DNA microarrays but at the end of the
day you're always using the fluorophores
as the probes for where certain things
are okay and that's the thing to
remember here fluorescence is a
magnificent tool we can use fluorophores
on their own we can use fluorophores
attached to antibodies and the DNA
microarray experiments show you how you
can use fluorophores attached to the DNA
sequences okay and I'll see you in the
next class
you